hi everyone this is Jerry and this is a
game analysis between Donald Byrne and
Bobby Fischer it was played in New York
City on October 17 1956 and at the time
Fischer was 13 years old and soon after
this game it was given the title game of
the century a rating and commenting are
appreciated in any questions you have
for me feel free to sign one my way hope
you enjoy the game burn opens the game
with the move Knight to f3 development
Fischer opens up with the Knight to f6
development pawn to c4 move directed at
controlling a central square d5 pawn to
g6 making way to fianchetto the King
Bishop to g7 Knight to c3 development
Bishop to g7 development and making way
to castle pawn to d4 establishing a pond
in the center in making way for the
Queen Bishop to develop castle
developing move getting the King safe
Bishop f4 development pawn to d5
signaling the green fell defense placing
a pawn in the center and also striking
at c4 Queen to b3 in directly attacking
d5 pawn captures pawn Queen captures
pawn and now both the Queen and Bishop
are directed at c7 Fischer follows up
with pawn to c6 if we just take a look
back it's worth noting that if Fischer
were to play pawn to c6 now white could
continue pawn to e3 and now if pawn
takes pawn the bishop has the option of
taking on c4 developing a new piece and
then getting ready to castle however by
capturing on c4 right now in this
position black does not give white the
possibility of taking on c4 with the
bishop because the pawn is still on e
too so as is often the case in chess
move order matters in this position
right here is no exception
so after Queen captures pawn how to meet
this threat you might be thinking well
why not develop a piece and prevent this
capture from occurring on c7 while that
might run into trouble with the move
like pawn to d5 the knight is shoot away
from c6 and then the pot could be taken
on c7 so that's why we see pawn to c6
on the e4 is the continuation I'm
establishing to get another pond in the
center and making way for the king
bishops development
Knight to d7 getting ready to come to b6
where we attacking the Queen it
temporarily obstructs the queen bishops
development an alternative would be
Knight to a6
staying out of the bishops way in
preparing upon the c5 advance where that
pawn would strike at d4 but instead we
see the knight coming to d7 and now rook
to d1 placing the rook opposite the
Queen Black has to be a bit careful
whenever a rook is opposite your own
Queen you have to be careful of tactics
going to be six attacking the Queen and
allowing the bishop to come out queen to
c5 a bit awkward maybe better is Queen
to b3 although maybe Byrne was turned
off to this move as a result of a
developing move to e6 where the bishops
now attacking the Queen Fischer is able
to take advantage of this Queens
placement shortly Fischer follows up
with Bishop to g4 pinning the knight to
the rook and Auburn plays Bishop to g5
violating one of the well-known
principles and chests which states you
should not move the same piece more than
once in the opening and this Bishop
initially came to f4 now it's going to
g5 this is not to be recommended
especially in this position Fischer is
now able to execute a series of
exceptional moves and it starts with
Knight to a4 deflecting the c3 Knight
from the defense of the e4 pawn the move
that was played in the actual game is
Queen 283 however it's worth taking a
look at what would occur if Knight takes
Knight this is what would happen Knight
takes pawn forking the Queen and Bishop
if Queen takes pawn that will result in
Queen takes Queen Bishop takes Queen
rook to e8 after the bishop moves and
they can come here discover check on the
Queen and the Knights going to be picked
off or maybe even the rook an
alternative is Bishop takes pawn that
will result in Knight takes Queen Bishop
takes Queen Knight takes Knight black is
doing better in this position as well
again ready to take the bishop pawn
another choice after Knight takes pawn
is Queen to c1 that'll result in Queen
to a5 checking the King hitting the
knight hitting the bishop if Knight
blocks Bishop takes Knight pawn takes
Bishop Knight takes bishop the Queen
can't take the knight because it's
protected and one other choice is to
pock with the bishop will result in
Knight takes Bishop Queen takes Knight
Queen takes Knight black is doing better
in this variation as well one more
choice after Knight takes here is Queen
to b4 that's going to result in Knight
takes bishop
Knight takes Knight Bishop takes rook
King takes Bishop Bishop takes pawn and
there's a nasty discomfort check that's
in the air after the bishop moves black
is doing better here as well so the move
that actually did get played is going to
a3 and now we see Knight takes Knight if
Queen takes Knight just Knight takes
pawn forking the Queen and Bishop so
pawn takes Knight was played and now
Knight still takes on e4 and allows this
fork Bishop captures pawn on e7 the rook
and queen are attacked Fischer follows
up with Queen to b6 if Bishop takes rook
that'll result in Bishop takes Bishop
the Queen's getting hit if Queen to b3
Knight takes c3 if Queen takes Knight
the bishop is going to win the Queen
because there's a pin if Queen takes
Queen pawn takes Queen the rook is still
hit the rook and Knight are both
converging on a2 and even though the
Queen's are still off the are off the
board the White King is still in trouble
if worked to a1 rook to e8 King here
Knight check f2 pawn will fall and the
white King is going to have a giant
headache to deal with because these
bishops are going to give them problems
so in this position the bishop did not
take the rook instead Byrne chose to
develop the Bishop to c4 and now we see
Knight takes c3 if Queen takes Knight
it's just the rook comes here pins the
bishop and the bishop will eventually be
won and so the move that was played is
Bishop to see
five attacking the Queen rook on f2 e8
it's important that it's this rook that
comes to e8 because there are
continuations where this a were a eight
rook will function well on the a file as
is the case in the actual game King to
f1 and now the move that caught
everyone's attention Bishop to e6
ignoring the threat on your own Queen
instead attacking the bishop one
continuation from here is to take the
knight if that did occur Queen captures
Bishop would be played seeing how
there's a pin against the Queen if pawn
takes Queen Bishop takes Queen if Bishop
will Front for this position if Bishop
takes Bishop that will lead to a
checkmate in six if you'd like to pause
the video and see if you can figure it
out it's a checkmate in six problem
okay the solution starts out with Queen
to b5 check Bishop blocks Queen captures
Bishop King to g1 Knight to e2 check
King the f19 to g3 that's double check
and double check the king must always
move King to g1 Queen to f1 check or
captures Queen the only movement now
Knight to e2 and that's me smothered
mate so the only other choice from here
is to just take the Queen and that's
what Byrne played in the actual game and
that ends up putting white in a lot of
hot water Bishop captures Bishop
checking the King King to g1 92 King f1
Knight captures pawn discovered check if
the bishop where's the rook blocks the
check that will result in pawn takes
Bishop the only way to now move the
Queen from the rooks attack is to play
to c3 and defend the rook that'll result
in Knight captures knight the bishop is
hitting the Queen after Queen captures
Bishop rook to e1 and that's mate so
that's why rook here is no good so white
unfortunately has to go back to g1 night
gives another check another check
discovered and the knight is heading the
rook King back to G 1 and now pawn
captures Bishop the Queen is being
attacked by the rook
Queen to b4 attacking the bishop black
first meets that threat with rook to a4
attacking the Queen and defending the
bishop and after Queen captures pawn
only now does black take the rook and
now it's just a matter of winning the
game from this point on pawn to h2
getting ready to sneak the King out and
then get the rook involved but it's too
little too late
Roe captures pawn king to h2 Knight
captures pawn attacking the rook rook to
e1 Roe captures rook and white throws a
check in first so that the bishop has to
work himself into a pin Bishop f8 and
now Knight tech Knight captures rook and
now we see Bishop to d5 from this point
on black just organizes all of his
pieces and gets it to a point where they
are all coordinated and as a result the
White Queen will not be able to attack
anything of blacks so Knight to f3
Knight to e4 Queen to b8 attacking b7
pawn to b5 upon h4 getting ready to come
to h5 and maybe smash up the kingside
structure but Fischer just stops that
right away pawn to h5 Knight to e5
getting ready to come to d7 where it
would be attacking the pinned piece so
Fischer just gets out of the pin King to
g7 and if you just take into account
this position right here everything is
protected of blacks the king guards the
pawn the bishop these pawns are
protected these pawns are protected in
this bishop here guards both the f7 pawn
the c6 pawn the knight and the rook
everything is strung together and as a
result the White Queen can do nothing
King to g1 and now it's just a matter of
mating the white king and it turns out
in the following way Bishop to c5 check
King to f1 Knight g3 check King b1 these
are all only moves Bishop check King to
d1
Bishop check King to c1 the king is
getting walked all the way along the
first rank Knight check King to be 193
check can you see one rook to c2 and
that's mate so that's all for this video
I hope you got something out of it take
care bye